logic programs over the course of the
past
couple of years we have been developing
a program that consists
of a few elements that have been tested
extensively by our partners
in various institutions in the u.s and
around the world
we have been working with a number of
institutions that have been
offering these materials to their
graduate
and undergraduate students as well as
high school students
and we've seen a lot of success in terms
of
students from different backgrounds
including non-engineering backgrounds
being able to learn about bioinformatics
as well as apply bioinformatics
to their research projects either
by themselves independently or working
as
as a group and with their faculty
for those of you that are just joining
if you have trouble
hearing the uh voice
or you have trouble seeing the slides we
will have a recorded
version of this presentation that we
will be uh putting on our social media
on youtube and you'll be able to see it
as well
importantly the program is developed in
collaboration with top faculty
at universities both in the us and
around the world
our major partner in developing the
materials
and the learning experience that we are
offering you
is with the talber bioinformatics
research center
the research center is located at
university of haifa
in israel and it has been
working on development on of a
multi-omics integration big data
analytics platform
called the t bioinfo platform
first let me briefly introduce myself
my name is elia brodsky i'm the ceo and
co-founder of pine biotech
and our mission at pine biotech is to
harness
big data to allow researchers to
leverage effective tools with
logic and understanding to make
discoveries
using high throughput omics data
so what we do in our company is develop
solutions for big data analysis and
help apply those solutions in an
effective way
by offering training and support to
research teams
in top universities
i am privileged to work with a team that
includes our
founders dr alfred tauber who is an
internationally recognized physician
with a background in immunology
and dr leonard brodsky who is a
well-recognized leader in the field of
bioinformatics with
hundreds of publications on development
of algorithm
as algorithmic approaches to analysis of
omics data as well as biostatistician
mathematician
including our team that is working to
develop
and support the platform as well as the
educational resources that we're going
to be offering you
as a part of this program julia panoff
is a phd student and a bioinformatician
at university of haifa in
israel with a specialization in
neurodegenerative diseases
avery tievsky who is a computer
scientist working on the development and
support of the team
for maltese high performance computing
platform
dr mohit mizunder who is a computational
biologist and we'll be
working closely with you in this program
to help you develop research projects
and
make sure that you have all the relevant
materials
and can succeed in the program
uh joshua mccandle and suraj patel who
are working on
developing the resources that we'll be
using including the educational portal
and the coding platform
and beeps biswas who i'm sure many of
you are already familiar with
she is our bioinformatics community
manager and she will be interacting with
you to make sure that all of the
logistics of the program are clear
and you have access to everything that
we will be using throughout this program
now we also have a trainer with us she
has
a phd in bioinformatics from the
bioinformatics center
csir institute of microbial technology
in chandigarh
india as well as from jnu in new delhi
in india
her phd is focused on the domain of
cancer genomics specifically
for liver cancer so dr harpreet kaur
will be assisting with conducting the
sessions in this program
as well as helping you understand and
clarify
any kinds of applications of
bioinformatics to the different project
examples
she has experience in both using big
data analysis tools
incorporating big data into usable
interfaces and databases has experience
in python and r and will be
um really key for those of you that want
to understand how bioinformatics is used
in
big data projects so her pre i would
like to pass it on to you now
so that you can maybe tell us a little
bit more about your background
thank you ilya so let me
share my shipping
okay thank you
so thank you everybody myself adrien as
already elia introduced me and
just look at just my educational
doctrine i have done my phd in
bioinformatics
and i have background especially my post
graduation in molecular biology and
biochemistry
and i have done my graduation in
biotechnology
so in my research interest i have
mainly focuses cancer genomics and
bioinformatics
machine learning biomarker discovery
and various bad resource development on
different aspect of the human health
so i have nearly 14 research
publications
with nearly 200 google scholar citations
and i got various awards
from european association for the study
of the lever as young
investigator overs river and then i have
got
institute of from the scholar as young
researcher awards
and i have got my scholarship from the
csir that is council of scientific and
industrial research
and this is what i have done my phd
so my phd is mainly focused in on the
topic
that is computer aided identification of
genetic biomarkers
for the predicting liver cancer and its
prognosis
we are apart from exploring the genomic
data
or omix data we have implemented
artificial intelligence approaches
and we have ah where we have applied
machine learning
plus survival analysis approach and
various
uh statistical analysis approaches
on three main omics layers that is rna
or the transcriptome there then
transcriptome and methylation layer
that is epigenetic and then rna
methylation and mrna so first of all we
have developed a resource
that is called cancer liver it is kind
of a knowledge base
where we have integrated information
related to already existing biomarkers
that is 594 biomarkers that are
associated with the liver cancer
and we have processed uh datasets that
are available in the
all different platforms using a
different uniform pipeline
for nearly 10 000 samples and we
ultimately integrated in form of a web
server called a cancer lever
and it is freely available in the second
work where i have focused on identifying
the
scc and discriminating scc from the
normal samples
and here we have mainly explored our rna
data
of the patients and we have identified
three
uh biomarkers that include clac 1b prc
and fcn3
to classify hcc samples from the normal
samples
here we have nearly used more than 4000
samples
and in the second part where we have
tried to classify the second
form of the liver cancer that is
plunging carcinoma
from hcc and the normal samples
and we have identified three genes that
is lamb c2 itca and c2
as cca specific signatures in the third
part we have tried to
classify early and the latest samples of
the scc patients
here we have explored rna and the
methylation data and we have identified
51 features that include 30 rna
transcripts
and 21 methylation cpg size to classify
early and the latest samples of the scc
in the last part we have tried to
predict the
reoccurrence risk groups using
three omics layers that is rna mir and
methylation
using survival analysis and we have
identified
90 rna features 50 mi rna features
and 50 methylation features that can
uh stratify high and low risk of the
reoccurrence risk of scc patients so let
me just explain only
two topics so first of all how we
process
these data sets and from where we have
downloaded these data sets for all these
studies
so here the two major public
repositories that is jio and the gdc
data portal
from where we have downloaded clinical
as well as
omix data set using various packages
like from the jio we have used jio query
package
and from gdc data portal we have
used gdc client packets and once we have
obtained the raw data sets
then we have used various
pre-processing packages to process these
data sets
like affi metrics is processed using
oligo package from the bioconductor
illumina from an aluminum asylum using
lima and lumi package
and high throughput sequencing is
followed uh
process that is followed by pcca
datasets
so finally we compile these data set and
clinical information
in form of matrix where sample is
present in the columns and genes are
present in the rows
so to further process these data sets we
have applied various
um various statistical approaches
and normalization approaches and finally
we have like we have performed quantile
normalization
to reduce any cross platform artifacts
using pre-process core packages
and then by applying machine learning on
the first project we have
we have 30 data sets and we have divided
these data set into three category
training and the differential gene
expression analysis
and two external four data sets we kept
for the external validation cohort
so first of all on 27 data sets that are
kept for differential expression
analysis which
contain nearly 2000 samples we have
performed differential gene expression
analysis
and we scrutinized 26 genes that were
found to be overlapping between scc and
the non-tumor samples
and once we have collected these 26
genes
then on the training dataset we have
tried to reduce these genes in such a
way that
the performance shouldn't be reduced we
should obtain a particular signature set
that
must have minimum number of the ah
number of the features so we have
applied various feature reduction
approaches so we finally come up with
the three genes that is fcn3 clack one
and prc one
and ah then we have developed prediction
machine learning prediction model models
we have explored various machine
learning classifiers here
like logistic regression svm rvf
lda bridge classifier and developed
various machine learning prediction
models
and finally performance of these models
is validated
and evaluated on external four external
validation cohorts
which contain at least more than samples
1500 samples
and eventually we have observed that
these uh
gene prediction model based on these
this three gene signature set
classifies uh hcc and the normal samples
with sensitivity specific accuracy
nearly 95
apart from uh criticizing its diagnostic
potential we have also analyzed its
prognostic potential
that is we whether these genes can also
predict
survival risk groups of scc patients so
here we have
considered two data set one is pcc and
gse
and then we have performed univariate
survival analysis
using two types of survival data that is
overall survival and disease free
survival or reoccurrence free survival
and finally we found that
these three genes uh independently
uh stratify survival risk groups of the
patients
with the p value less than point zero
five and has a risk
at least one point five and uh
eventually these prediction models are
uh integrated in form of a web server
that is scc pred
and this paper is published in january
uh in frontier in general
genetics in the january 2020
in the second project we have tried to
classify early and the late stage
samples
based on two types of data here we have
explored
rna expression data and methylation data
so we have
first we have uh divided these data set
into early and the late stage samples
and then we have divided these datasets
based on training and validation cohorts
so to reduce as the number of the
features is very large that is 60 000
rna transcript
and nearly 5 lakh cpt size so we have
applied first differential expression
analysis approach and differential
methylation
and we found nearly 103 rna transcript
and 40
103 rna transcript and for nearly 450
methylation cpd site to further reduce
features from this we have applied
various feature selection approaches
that is k best fcvf simple threshold
based so finally we obtain 30 rna
transcript and 21 cpd size
and then prediction model waste we have
developed various machine learning
prediction model
and we have observed the uh prediction
model based on them able to classify
uh early and the late stage sample with
more than 75
accuracy then we try to combine them and
performance is improved to
nearly 79 so this uh
finally all the prediction models are
integrated in form of a web server that
is cancer nsp
and this paper is published in january
2019
in plos one and here my
my main focus is how i can help you any
participants in
understanding the bioinformatics
application through lectures tutorials
or any kind of research projects so
i'm happy to help you uh all the
research interns
in this their research projects their
proposal and analysis designs
thank you thank you very much harpreet
and for all of you that are interested
to learn more
about harpreet's background as well as
her
um research projects you're welcome to
to
uh look her up on the edu t-bio
portal she has a profile and
has gone through the materials that we
are sharing with you
extensively and we hope that this
program is going to be effective for you
as well as it was for her
so what are we going to learn in onyx
logic transcriptomics
in this program we will see how relying
on analytical methods
and reference databases researchers can
study rna-seq data to understand how
gene expression variation is studied
across
many different conditions to do so
effectively
bioinformaticians leverage big data sets
processing methods organized into
bioinformatics pipelines
and perform exploratory data analysis
normalization
statistical analysis and rigorous
hypothesis testing
so in this program we will cover all
aspects
of this process from exploring the data
to making sure that the data is ready
for analysis
and then learning how to train and
understand the validation and the
accuracy of such machine learning
methods as you've seen today
we will also discuss the future of
rna-seq
and how rna-seq analysis has been
changing
over time because of the changing
technologies
including single cell rna-seq
next generation sequencing allows us to
study
data at the subcellular level so
whenever we talk about
phenotype we're typically talking about
a description
of an external characteristic of a
sample
as we go deeper we can understand the
variation
genomic level study epigenomic variation
and what we are talking about today is
the analysis of
expression data expression data
primarily focuses on two
aspects the first one is an is gene
and isoform expression and because genes
are typically not produced
in the exact same way across all
conditions and patients
or organisms we're also going to be
talking about
alternative splicing
so when we talk about mrna we're
actually discussing the process
of translating the code that is in the
dna
before it becomes a protein for example
when we speak about her2 as a protein
that is being expressed and used for
diagnostic purposes
we can capture the mrna that encodes for
the her2 protein
and understand how it is produced in
what quantities
as well as what types of variations we
can find
from what is regularly been noticed in
healthy
samples so when we talk about expression
of mrna and alternative splicing of
mrna we can explore
and annotate the quantities and the
variation
of specific messenger rna that are
likely to become
either complete fully functioning or
potentially
alternatively functioning proteins that
are used
for a variety of purposes when we
previously uh used micro
uh microarray technologies to study
mrna expression this was done using
uh hybridization um
which is uh unfortunately not as
detailed
as next generation sequencing
for rna-seq so in this program we will
primarily focus
on the expression analysis using next
generation sequencing
using such platforms as the aluminum
platform
which have a broader dynamic range
allow us to study both the quantities
and the variation at the isoform level
in many cases isoforms have been shown
to have an additional informative
component
to distinguish between different types
of conditions
an important aspect that we will
highlight in the beginning
of this program ultimately when we turn
to bioinformatics
our goal is to find associations between
various types of data
including the association between
clinical
data and omics data which allows us to
understand how different diseases
that we described in clinical terms are
represented
at the subcellular level at the
molecular level
and potentially how this can change the
way that
diagnostics and therapeutics are being
used
in precision medicine but in the program
we will also cover
other projects that are not related to
medical applications
for the biomedical projects using
rna-seq data we will study
such topics as diagnostics of tumor
biology
including the differences between the
tumor and the micro-environment
we will look at disease classification
and patient stratification
which is something that harpreet alluded
to in her presentation
as well as look at single cell and
tissue composition
important new frontiers being opened up
by single cell rna sequencing
so overall in this program we will have
six different sessions in our first
session today
we're going to review the tools and
resources
that we will use throughout this program
and how
they will build up the skills and the
important
background understanding for all of the
participants to start
working on independent projects then we
will focus
on processing pipelines pipelines that
combine multiple scripts and algorithms
including pre-processing mapping and
quantification
to produce a table of expression then we
will turn
to the analysis exploration
normalization and visualization of
individual genes and isoforms as well as
bulk understanding of data so that we
can explore
patterns and understand what is
in the data that we have processed
then we will turn to the second part of
the program when we will talk about
big data mining machine learning and
predictive analysis
introduce single cell rna-seq data and
turn to
hands-on project examples where we will
cover
important examples in cancer infectious
diseases
and different types of biotechnology
applications
when you have registered you probably
saw that we provide a detailed schedule
for the program after you complete the
registration
the next step is to join the omics logic
program which is a section on the
educational portal that we have
where all of these materials are clearly
explained
and combined together into a
syllabus for the program so to talk a
little bit about
the program logistics and how they are
organized i'm going to pass this on to
bibsa bishwas
thank you
i hope everyone can see my screen uh
so okay thank you
so i will start with how the
registration process works for those of
you
who are joining us for the first time or
are yet to register
so this is uh the registration page
when you come on this page as elia has
been showing
you see we have all of the sessions
listed down the
different dates of the program and
the topics that we will be covering for
the program so if you go down
you will be finding that uh there are
some reviews from participants who had
been part of
omits logic programs previously then you
can look at the courses which are
available
so to register all you have to do is if
you click on the pricing option
you will see that there are three
options that you can register with and
they all come with different prices and
they all have
uh different features associated with
them
and just to quickly go over these
features so the basic
membership is something that everyone
has access
to and you will have as part of this
program for the intermediate
membership any participant who opts for
this membership will also
get access to one-on-one mentor sessions
if they require assistance during the
entire length of the next
one month and for the advanced courses
especially for participants who are
doing a research project and need more
guidance and more time
we'll be giving them an extension of one
more month
where they can actually go ahead and
work with our own group of research
interns
who will be also working closely on
projects
and also with our mentors so once you
see here
if you select each of these options you
can go ahead and complete your
registration
so once your registration is done you
come
to this page so this is one of the
resources that
all of you have access to and this is
the
educational organization page so
we treat the organization page as what
you would typically treat
a classroom as like a lot of people
learning together
in one place so it can call it a virtual
classroom
so you see here we have uh different
tabs
which i'm coming to very soon you see
the
program description here you do not need
to register for all events if you are
already registered for the program
and you can see that uh today we are
here on 15
september so if you go around you can
see all the different dates the program
is going to be
here you can see all the other
participants in the program who are
doing the different courses and what
they are
exploring so you can actually connect
with another person as part of the
program
and work together and there are
different tabs
so uh we are going to be coming to our
faculty so
if you go down here right in the menu
you have a few more resources
faculty and syllabus that you can go
through
then you have the forum so the forum
would be a main point of conversation
and communication
between you and us so if you have any
questions you can
actually put them down in the forum
there are already a few topics
that you can create and you can also
post about
every day the session recordings will be
posted here
so in case you do not find the email you
can again
come back to the forum and check the
session recording
all participants will have also the
links to these
which i have already emailed uh to them
and if you have not received it you can
again reach out to me
and also we feature top performers every
week
on the basis of the asynchronous courses
which they do
and these are a few of the asynchronous
courses that you will have
access to so each of these courses come
with their own certificates which are
different from the
entire omics logic transcriptomics
program certificate so you can earn
both in addition to the omics logic
program certificate and if you look here
there are also the members of the
program you can go to everybody's
profile
and have a look at what the other person
is doing
there are also some asynchronous
projects
which are associated and given as part
of this
program and you will be able to explore
these projects
like you do the asynchronous courses
so here is also another tab which is the
progress tab so the progress tab shows
your progress
as a group as a whole and you will be
able to see it so right now we have just
started so there is not much
progress as we go through the different
weeks you will be able to see the
performance of the entire group here and
also the different points that you will
be earning
on the education portal so the points
you earn on the education portal are by
doing
the courses and i'm also going to be
demonstrating
uh them very soon and
there are also points for the server
access
so if anyone else who has not received
the server access you'll be getting them
soon today so each of these adds to the
points and also adds to
the entire course certificate that you
would be getting
so we offer two kinds of certificates
one is a certificate of excellence and a
certificate of participation
any participant who has over 10 000
points
is awarded the certificate of excellence
and also anybody who does
a project so going
forward i just wanted to introduce
everybody
uh to what a profile looks like now you
all have profiles when you join the
program
so i'm just using connor's profile as an
example here so you can see that corner
is already registered
he has all of his social media links if
you are a researcher and you have an
orcid id you can actually add that or
you can add any
of your social media links we would
recommend that you definitely add your
linkedin id because a lot of our people
collaborate with each other within the
community and
they would be reaching out to you as
well
so and you can see the points that
connor has collected
after doing a few of the courses that he
has completed
so conor has already been a part of a
different program with us
and you can see that his certificate is
also there from a previous program
so conor has updated his profile
completely
uh yes and now just uh going back to the
chat so siddhant yes
siddhant you will have access to all of
these courses
right so how to edit your profile so a
lot of you
will see that your profile is not
updated meaning that your name
is probably a username you will have to
update your full name because
this will be uh displayed in the course
certificates that you will be getting
here
so you can go just to profile and the
edit option
and you will be able to edit all of
these fields right here
so and moving on i just wanted to show
the
course certificates and the courses so
here you will see the courses that you
are
taking or you are enrolled in so if you
go to certificates
uh from here
you will be able to see that the
different certificates that
you have got for the different programs
right
so right now conor has no certificate so
moving on there are also
two other platforms that you will have
access to this is our code omixlogic
platform which our mentors would be
showing you in a few more minutes
and the other is the server tbio info
platform
so with this i'm going to be uh stopping
my screen share either if you can please
uh take over thank you so much
thank you and it's great to see
all of the questions we will definitely
be covering many of these topics
as we go on so as beeps have mentioned
your profile is the center where you
will see
all of your activity you will be able to
also
see the different types of uh activity
like
pipelines or completing your lessons or
even
running some exercise on the coding
platform all of it is going to be
integrated using our point system which
gives both
us and you an indication of where you
are
excuse me compared to other participants
of the program
course has a number of quizzes
and you will be able to review those and
try them
several different times you will also
see your progress over time
so that you can evaluate how much effort
goes into completing the individual
exercises and assignments
and at the end as beeps mentioned you
will receive a certificate
as well as a certificate for completing
courses
and an overall certificate for the full
program
so let's review several different
elements
that this program relies on one of them
is interactive sessions just like we're
having today
the goal of interactive sessions is to
provide a live
review of the topics and give you some
practical exercises that you can do
together
with a guided with a guided presentation
by a mentor
in between the sessions you can rely on
self-guided study materials
to complete asynchronous courses work on
projects
practice coding exercises and running
pipelines
and then the practical assignments are
going to be given
every several sessions so that you have
enough time to practice
and work on your own if there are any
technical
challenges those will be reviewed in the
interactive sessions
the coursework that we've prepared for
this program
includes transcriptomics 1 2 3
and 4. you can see it on this link edu
dot t
bio dot info collections transcriptomics
or under the program
which is under the courses tab
each course has several elements that
you will see
as you go to that course page it starts
off with an
introductory video
and inside the course you will have
several different additional resources
that you can benefit from there are
different topics that are included
and keywords underlined
you can also download the full course
material as a pdf
there's a lesson forum where you can ask
questions
and get answers and you can also
manipulate the font size and images that
you can
zoom in or increase the font size
so inside the course you will see that
there are both
technical explanations again with key
terms that are highlighted that you can
learn from if you're not familiar with
those words
and it's important to remember that we
try to prepare these materials for
both people that do have a background in
cell and molecular biology and
bioinformatics and those that do not
so we're trying to really make it easy
for anyone to jump in
and benefit the most from the materials
you will also see
that we highlight both the biological
and the data or computer science aspects
explaining both the way data is
generated and what it represents
as well as the methods and analytical
approaches
and some basic logic behind some of
those methods
so in our practical assignments you will
see that we first review
how to do some kind of an analysis and
then offer you a chance to practice it
on your own
providing you feedback for each one of
your submitted assignments
you will also get points for completing
those assignments
and those will be limited for a certain
period of time
most of the assignments inside the
courses will leverage the big data
analysis t-biome for platform
now this is a resource that is
expensive to um to offer uh
so we only offer it to the participants
of the program
and we are trying to make sure that the
resources are used efficiently
in other words the pipelines that you
are going to be using will go from
simple to more complex we'll first try
it
using the demos and then eventually give
you a lot more
guidance on how to prepare a pipeline
that is meaningful
before you actually start working on an
independent project
so once you submit an assignment that
will typically include
the result of a pipeline that you might
have
done some visualization with or done
some statistical analysis with
let me show you how the platform works
the platform is a big data
bioinformatics analysis platform
designed for biologists and clinicians
it is not intended only for those that
plan to be bioinformaticians or are
currently bioinformaticians
our goal is to make these complex tools
for big data sets
accessible to anyone
inside the platform
there is a color-coded scheme that you
can follow
understanding the logic of why each
individual section is being used
and a color-coded number of buttons
that connect together explaining how the
pipeline actually works
in the process of building this pipeline
you also get to learn
about each step what it means and what
kinds of
input and output data sets are being
produced
every step of the way as a result
you will get visual and graphical
outputs
that help you understand the meaning of
the data that you have analyzed
let me briefly show you how it works
to see the platform you go to
server.dashbio.info
for those of you that have already
completed your registration
you will know that you are logged in by
seeing your email address
right here under this icon
if you still have not received your
details
please be patient you will receive them
either today or tomorrow
one of the processing sections that we
will use is right here under
transcriptomics called
rna-seq chip parallel analysis of ngs
and microarray data
there are several demo examples that we
will review
in the next few lessons in this
transcriptomics
program once you're in
you will see that the buttons that you
can use are highlighted in black
by pressing on the button you learn
about each step
for example this first step will load
the data for analysis
now you have a few options that you can
choose from
for example if we want to map on the
genome
and understand the top hat
algorithm we can click right here
my next steps have been limited to only
the steps that make sense
after i process the data using top hat
too
for each method it's important to
understand how it
varies from other methods and what
exactly
is the type of analysis that it does
eventually as you start building up your
pipeline
you learn about the process of
transforming the data from raw reads
into a table of structured data
in the structured data you end up with a
table
called a table of expression
once the pipeline is complete you click
on end
and you can see the files that the
pipeline has produced
these files could be tables sometimes
pdfs
or dynamic links where you can visualize
the data
for example we will learn about
individual reads
how those reads are generated by a next
generation sequencing machine
and how they are visualized by mapping
them
onto a reference genome we will also
learn
about how to perform downstream analysis
of this data
and explore what it means about the
individual genes
the bulk data across all of our samples
and how to understand what it might mean
in association with
a phenotype for example a clinical
subtype of a cancer patient
in transcriptomics 2 we will continue to
review
downstream analysis of such data
thinking about hypothesis testing and
regression
when we explore the association between
a condition
or multiple conditions and factors that
are included in experimental design
we will learn about complex gene
expression patterns
and understand how to perform different
types of normalization and
transformation of our data
to make it more more appropriate
for such high hypothesis testing
in transcriptomics 3 we will turn to
machine learning and data mining
so we will discuss how complex data sets
like rna-seq
could be used for training machine
learning models
exploring different types of patterns in
the data
and finding groups or making
interpretation
based on model prediction we will look
at how
principal component analysis could be
performed using
r as well as on the platform
and learn about different types of
methods of data visualization
exploration data mining and
classification
in r studio and in python
an additional resource that you will
have for this program
is our code omixlogic.com
code playground
in the code playground you will see how
what happens behind the scenes how
individual buttons that you click
are actually coded and how to manipulate
the code
so that it is more useful for the type
of analysis that you want to do
it provides a cloud-based environment
that eliminates the need for
installing different libraries and
packages storing all of the files on
your computer
and avoids the technical back and forth
that is typically required
when you're just getting started with
code
in the context of this program we will
cover several modules that include
how to load data and check for variable
data types
how to run descriptive statistics and
visualization
do dimensionality reduction with
principal component analysis
and do differential gene expression
using such packages as dc2
and edge r we will also talk about
different types of clustering
and classification let's take a look at
an
example
for example when we talk about the
differential
gene expression analysis it's important
to understand
how the data is loaded what types of
transformations
are done before we actually perform the
statistical analysis
and what do the different outputs
actually mean
once you run the data you get an
editable code
that you can modify understand
each section and run right here
in the browser to get the results based
on a cloud server
that runs the package in r and the data
sets that are discussed and explained
in the program itself so such analysis
can take
a little bit of time but it's much
easier to go through this together in
class
understand any challenges being able to
monitor
all of the activity together once you
get the outputs
you can actually save this piece of code
and go to your computer
continuing to edit and include it
into your jupyter notebook or some kind
of a shared resource that you will
include
in your final project
finally we will start talking about the
future
of rna-seq and it is obvious that when
we talk about complex diseases
and variation at the subcellular level
we should be looking at how this
variation plays out
in individual tissues and even
individual
cells as opposed to the full organism
or the system to do that we'll discuss
different approaches for single cell
rna-seq that have been developing since
2009
and today are becoming an exciting
resource that allows us to understand
and study different types of biomedical
projects
so we will talk about different types of
methods to produce such data
and downstream analysis that also
has emerged as several pipelines for
processing such data
and visualization importantly
we will apply all of these two tools to
basic research
and translational research projects that
include
patient-derived cell lines xenograft
models
and even clinical trials and
translational applications for studying
how
to predict and assign different types of
therapeutic interventions
for example we will focus on the
evolution of breast cancer
classification
and take real publications that offer us
an
insight into how big companies like
genentech
and big research consortia like the
cancer genome atlas
studied such variation and what kinds of
conclusions do they come to when they
analyze
such data
importantly after completing this
program you will be able to reach such
publications with much greater
understanding
learning about how to interpret both the
technical
and the molecular biology side
of each subject that you're covering
and how to apply your understanding and
skills
to perform similar analysis
so we already heard from dr harpreet
kaur
and now i wanted to introduce you to dr
mahint mazumdar
who is going to be our project mentor
for this program
to talk a little bit more about research
projects
and how you can benefit from research
projects in this program
mohit
thank you good morning everyone
and yeah thank you india for guiding us
through the program
and let me share my screen
[Music]
okay elia is showing that i cannot share
my screen
um yeah one sec
go ahead yeah so
just a second
right so to everyone joining us
uh for the first time my name is mohit
mazumdar i have a phd in computational
biology
and uh i have been working on various
bioinformatics projects
in the context of biological research
problems
to provide bioinformatics solutions uh
starting from you know working from
hypothesis
to publication other than research i am
developing educational bioinformatics
curriculum by collaborating with
universities around the globe
so it has been more than a year and a
half working with omix logic
participants
uh as you saw the program you know
starts with registration and then
developing an understanding of ngs data
generation
followed by deep diving into the gene
expression transcriptomic state analysis
right for so for number of years
uh our team has been working on project
driven bioinformatics training
programs that are designed to help you
find develop and complete such
you know research and research projects
so
as a result of this experience we want
to offer
you several suggestions to make the most
out of your research project whether
you're a part of one of the omics logic
programs
or working independently there are
plenty of opportunities
to learn from this resource
moreover uh talking about the portal uh
on this portal you'll find
like-minded people with about the
community that we discussed
so that will help you reflect on your
ideas
develop answers to common questions or
you can be presenting to other members
of the program
and get important feedback from the from
your peers
so using these examples participants can
develop independent or group projects
during the program so many of our past
participants had a chance
you know to present their analysis in
front of their classmates or even
conference poster sessions and workshops
so just to give you an
overview uh once you have learned about
the
ngs data analysis by working with us
uh on various examples uh and
interested and then you're interested
you know once you're you're
confident and you have learned about the
data analysis and you have seen
how transcriptomics data is being used
in this sub
in these several of examples research
examples
then uh you are interested to work on an
independent
project so for that once the omixlogic
program is finished or maybe you are
learning and
you're working on your own project we
have designed a specialized
program for our omics logic participants
to carry out
individual and group projects in
collaboration with pine biotech
and our university partners so
the omixlogic fellowship program
guides researchers to develop and work
on
uh ngs data analysis and
that is driven by you know it's a
bioinformatics project
so the program is structured and starts
with you know framing the problem so we
start with framing the problem
or develop a title and then identify a
data set
or data sets and references so it's
important
it's very critical and important stage
of
of the research or the research project
is to identify a data set
and find those references so after that
we work on preparing the data
processing the data for uh analysis and
then
perform your analysis analyze the data
in
depth using machine learning and we have
already showed you the platform so we
have uh
several machine learning techniques that
i've implied once you have
you know under have the understanding so
after that interpretation of the result
so biological interpretation
so that's a program that is structured
and many of our past participants had a
chance to present their analysis
in front of their classmates or even you
know in several
conferences as i said and one of the
examples is olga
so she is a postdoctoral researcher at
roswell park cancer center
and used her experience you know to
learn about data analysis
techniques she's now applying in her own
you know pre-clinical research
so she's using her knowledge for uh real
research projects
which has uh data from coming uh from
a hospital so many other
many others who have continued to
benefit from the resources and the
training of this omixlogic program so
you are a participant and
we expect and we would want you to
have a maximum benefit out of this
programs so
this starts from the beginners level to
uh you know faculty and industry
professionals
so we have had all those uh people who
have joined us
and have equally benefited from these
programs so
for those who still have to complete
their registration
we would welcome you to join this
program and earn a certificate of
excellence for advanced projects
or a certificate of participation for
basic training so
the sessions will guide you will help
you and the additional resources that
you saw
and then you have support you know you
have
the trainers you have the mentors so
let me now pass it to ilya for uh maybe
conclusive remarks and the rest of the
session
so if you have any question please reach
out to us my email address i'll just put
it in the chat
move it at the rate pine dot bio and
we can communicate through the forum as
well
so that is there
it's really happy to have you on it yeah
thank you india
so i think that this program is going to
allow all of the participants to both
explore the basics of rna-seq
data analysis understand how it applies
to several different examples
practice those tools and develop some
basic skills
and work with our team to develop and
conduct your research
in the course of this program which is
about one month
or right after that by joining a mentor
guided
research fellowship as muay just
explains
in the program itself you will have
access to projects as well
these include several publications that
we have went through
and converted into educational data sets
that you can
work on and understand all of the
different aspects
that you will have to have in your mind
as you analyze and interpret that data
as
mohit mentioned the outcome of that
process is being able to present
a poster or a presentation in front of
our
peers in the program and potentially
continue on to present this at different
types of conferences
right now is a great opportunity to join
interactive online poster presentations
at a variety of poster sessions around
the
world
our mentors that you have seen in this
program
and the interns in our intern and
research fellowship programs
are here to continue and support your
work
and we're going to be working with you
in the second part of the program
to make sure that the projects are both
impactful
and satisfying to you
whatever your objective is whether it is
developing your career
making sure that you are ready to join a
specific research lab
or even just for your personal research
as a pi
or a researcher in a lab
so as monkey mentioned in the course of
this program
you will learn rna-seq data processing
analysis and interpretation
you will be able to leverage cloud-based
tools for hands-on assignments
apply machine learning to large
biomedical data sets
complete and present independent
research projects and obtain a
certificate of excellence and
recognition
based on your achievements in this
program
thank you for joining today's session i
encourage everybody to just
make sure before we leave for those of
you that have completed the registration
by going on to the home page
for the amix logic transcriptomics
program
make sure that your profile is complete
as beeps are mentioned and that you
start reviewing some of the
resources that she highlighted in the
logistics part of this presentation
you will also find our individual
profiles and you can reach out directly
to us
or post any questions you might have on
the forum
and we are excited to see you
in our next session you can learn about
the schedule of these
interactive sessions and associated
courses by going to
the syllabus tab and on the syllabus tab
you will see
that today this was our
program overview session we asked
everybody to start with going through
the introduction to bioinformatics
course
now the reason for going through that
course
is because it also includes an important
survey that will help us understand
more about you and more about your
background
so we are here to talk to you about what
we know about rna-seq
but we're also extremely interested to
learn more about you
which includes your research interests
so we want to understand what you are
interested in
we're also interested to understand your
level of education so what is your
background
what is your technical background if you
know anything about bioinformatics or is
this completely new to you
if you have done some research using
rna-seq
data or you have not and also
to see how we can best help you
throughout this program so if you go to
the syllabus tab
and beeps if you don't mind putting the
link
in the chat there as well you will see
that
after this first session we actually
will
ask you to complete this introduction to
bioinformatics course
and in our next session we will pick up
from here and continue talking
about uh going through the next
generation sequencing processing steps
uh and what is uh the meaning of
every single step and why would we want
to take
one option or the other for those of you
that will be continuing with this
program that have completed your
registration
please add marking at pine.bio to your
contact list you will be receiving
emails with links to next sessions
they're going to be different from this
zoom link
uh you will also get important
announcements about the program
and additional resources that we will be
using in the sessions themselves
so thank you again for joining today we
are excited for this program to start
and we will be looking forward to seeing
you in our next session
and now i'll just open this for
questions if anyone has any questions so
let's take the first one parisa is
asking and work on fungal and material
genome
do we have any courses related to dna
seek analysis of those creatures
so we just completed a metagenomics
program that does look at
different types of bacterial genomes
and so we encouraged you to take a look
at introduction to
metagenomics metagenomics one and two
we also have a project that deals with
some
viral sequencing data
so yes we'll be happy to share that
please leave your
email so that we can uh communicate with
you by email and send you these links
okay about any logistics or any kinds of
questions that you might have about the
program and joining program please email
marketing
at pine dot bio
for the code uh what code will be saved
and how can we re-access the same so all
of the code
is actually going to stay accessible
so you can see right here my code has
finished
i can see the outputs but also i can
save the code now similarly to this
in the pipelines that i showed you on
the server big data platform
you will have a number of different
methods that you can run and then save
the code
onto your computer for how that code was
run
with your input files and with all of
the settings
so all of this material is something
that you just store on your computer
and directly open in your rstudio or
any kind of python ide and
obviously once your environment is set
up and you've got all the same packages
it should run exactly the same on your
computer
will the projects that we will be doing
in this program be suitable for
publication
um so whenever we
uh deal with uh real research projects
it's important to remember
and harpreet and mohit can probably
add to this it takes a while
right to do to collect the data to
analyze and explore the data
eventually coming to a real
kind of a research level publication
level
project so typically we see that that
takes
anywhere between 3 to 12 months
so that's why in the context of this
program the project that you're likely
to complete
is going to be one of your first steps
so you're going to just
develop a sense of what you're
interested in develop a project title
explore the data make some preliminary
analysis
and potentially have some interesting
results that you can then continue to
develop into a real
full research proposal because it takes
a longer time
and it also requires many different
types of
assistance that are very specific to
that project
instead of a program that has a detailed
plan it's a kind of a rolling basis
you can enroll into the research
fellowship to benefit from the tools
the mentorship and the support that we
offer
through this program
do we need specific notebook on my
computer system so that saved code can
be re-accessed
um well all code if i save it it
actually
can you can open in any text editor it's
just code
to run it however you probably will
benefit from
installing an environment for example
rstudio
or just the r packages that will be used
in python it's the same way you can run
python scripts from the terminal
but you will have to install python and
install different packages
there are also developer environments
that are integrated and provide you with
some environment where you can easily
access the files the outputs the code
itself
kind of learn the syntax etc so we will
review some of those aspects in the
program as well
which language is better python or r
there is a debate about which one is
more popular
you know better needs to be defined more
i think
you know are we talking about efficiency
are we talking about
ease of use are we talking about how
they handle you know different types of
data sets or maybe what packages are
available
so i think you know that's an open
discussion
um do i need to be affiliated some
university or do a project for a
research fellowship no you don't need to
be a part of a university we have many
independent
participants that join that program as
well
you know the university provides you
with um
an environment and that's what our
program seeks to provide as well
uh in fact beeps if you could share
links to our social media groups on
linkedin
and on facebook we have groups with
several hundred of participants that
have
either completed or participated in some
way
in our omixlogic programs you will see
that they include
different levels of students at
different universities
researchers as well as faculty and
industry professionals so we are
continuously building a community of
participants
that can help each other by providing
feedback
potentially collaboration and there's a
lot of opportunities to
for employment for research in different
labs
etc
basic r or python that could be used in
genomic data science
um yes in the context of this program
you will start from the very basics so
in fact
one of the first lessons that we will go
through is how to load
and check for variables in both
r and python so i think you're going to
be starting from the very basics if you
don't know any coding at all
you can join this program to learn both
the coding and the application to
rna-seq data
we will have another program that is
called omix logic data science
that program will start in october
november and so
you can benefit from just more of a data
science perspective a much more
detailed review of the different coding
practices
uh different data science applications
all related to genomic or biomedical
data sets
and on keith if you want to share your
email with us we will be happy to email
you the
the details of that program as well
okay are there any other questions
okay excellent thank you for joining
today again
those are some of our social media
groups thank you mohit for sharing those
links
you can join the linkedin group we have
a wide variety of professionals from the
industry from
academia previous participants of these
programs you can learn about
how they benefit from this program and
what are the outcomes some of them got
hired some of them
went on to do their research etc so
you will benefit from interacting with
those
participants as well do you need to read
anything to prepare for tomorrow's
session
yes please go through the introduction
to bioinformatics course
so we will definitely include you again
if you have any questions about
assignments for the next class you
should be able to see them
on this page right here so you see that
for today's session the assignment is to
complete the introduction to
bioinformatics course
as i mentioned the introduction to
bioinformatics
is an overview of how bioinformatics is
applied
to a variety of different types of
challenges in the life sciences
in general including agriculture
biomedicine and others
and one of the first lessons is going to
be
a survey that we ask all of you to fill
in this survey we are looking to learn
about you
so that we understand how we can best
organize the materials
and make it the program effective for
you
so if you could finish this course you
will also learn about how
this resource will work throughout the
program
okay so thank you again all of you for
joining today please share this program
with your contacts we're looking forward
to building a long-term relationship
that we hope will be beneficial to all
of us
and we want to of course see you in our
next session
and continue this conversation thank you
everyone